bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors faut-il
demander des contreparties sur l'emploi
aux entreprises du cac 40 qui ont perçu
des aides de l'état les aides publiques
elles doivent être conditionnés vous
quand vous avez une aide
vous devez justifier par exemple quand
vous recherchez un emploi mais il faut
justifier de cette recherche d'emploi
pour pouvoir bénéficier de l'aide
ça semble logique pour des millions de
français il me semble que ça doit être
la même logique qui doit s'appliquer aux
entreprises du cac 40
or qu'est ce qu'on constate c'est qu'il
y à une avalanche dette de l'état à des
entreprises qui sert des dividendes et
qui demande des efforts aux salariés qui
leur est qui bénéficient du chômage
partiel des exemples si on atteint 1
il y en a pas deux il y en a plusieurs
puis à danone orange
capgemini bref on pourrait faire une
liste hélas ce qu'on apprend c'est que
maintenant on a carrément des
entreprises qui vont faire grâce à ces
aides publiques ont faire financer des
plans de licenciement c'est le cas de
renault comme vous le disiez mais c'est
aussi le cas de deux cas benji le cas
d'air france donc on voit que c'est z et
ben l'état souffre les lobbys mais le
sauve pas les entreprises
et ça c'est un problème pas en parlant
de suppressions d'emplois les syndicats
de renault mais aussi d'air france de
angie sont inquiets d'éventuelles
suppressions justement à l'issue de
cette crise
vous pensez qu'ils ont raison de l'être
bien sûr on va prendre le cas de renault
rno ces 5 milliards que l'état va leur
prêter alors qu'on sait que c'est une
entreprise qui emploie des milliers
d'intérimaires que c'est une entreprise
qui a servi des milliards pendant les
six dernières années c'est une
entreprise qui ne respectent pas les
règles sanitaires et on apprend qu'elle
va fermer quatre usines mais mais ce
sont des charognards qu'on a en face
pourquoi doit-on accepter cela les
restructurations on voit qu'elles vont
être uniquement là pour préserver les
profits et non pas pour préserver les
emplois et saas etc on peut pas accepter
ça on ne doit pas accepter ça parce que
la variable d'ajustement dans leur
logique ça a toujours été les emplois
non aujourd'hui la variable d'ajustement
ce sont les profits sont les
actionnaires on voit que lorsque tout va
bien quand lorsque la bourse va bien eh
ben les profits ils se les gardent les
mains aujourd'hui si la bourse va mal
leur logique c'est toujours de
socialiser les pertes et privatiser les
profits socialiser les pertes on doit
plus répondre à cette logique là
aujourd'hui la logique elle doit être
différente parce qu'il faut faire
différemment il ya d'autres façons de
faire aussi alors justement la crise est
là quand même durement touché l'économie
mondiale c'est un peu logique aussi que
l'état français aident ces entreprises à
surmonter cette crise qu qu'en pensez
vous il ya d'autres façons de faire je
vous le disais c'est bien sûr que oui
que l'état doit aider les entreprises
mais il doit apporter des conditions des
conditions écologiques parce que ces
entreprises doivent être accompagnés
vers la reconversion des conditions
sociales aucun licenciement boursier
elle semble logique et également des
conditions financières c'est à dire que
cet argent ne doit pas être là pour
financer les actionnaires ni verser des
salaires mirobolants au pdg
ça ce sont des conditions mais
maintenant il faut aussi une
planification et cette planification
l'état se refuse à la faire parce qu'on
sait très bien que quand on fait une
planification
la première chose que vous servez en
premier c'est l'intérêt commun quand on
fait une planification on est là pour
organiser et la planification vous savez
ça n'a rien de bolchévique
la france l'a déjà fait et compris
d'ailleurs pour l'automobile en 1945 la
france avait une planification un plan
uniquement dédié à l'automobile ça
s'appelait même le plan pons et ben ce
plan il organisait la production et il
disait à chaque producteur
ce qu'il devait produire et ce qu'ils ne
devaient pas d'où vous voyez bien
qu'aujourd'hui l'état se refuse de faire
ça parce que on a toujours le même
logiciel en face à savoir le modèle
libéral
la loi du marché doit primer sur tout
cette loi du marché aujourd'hui n'a plus
lieu d'être
il faut une planification parce que
devant nous nous avons une urgence
immédiate et une urgence écologique et
ça c'est notre en gros enjeu
malheureusement ce que je constate c'est
que l'état est impuissant
parce qu'il est toujours dans le dogme
alors il ya eu un dispositif de chômage
partiel
est-ce que ça un dispositif suffisant
12,7 millions de français ont été
concernés selon le ministère du travail
le problème de ces mesures c'est que ce
sont des mesurettes c'est à dire qu' il
n'y a pas derrière de volonté
industrielle
or c'est de ça dont on a besoin
aujourd'hui il faut une volonté pour
relocaliser faire une industrie locale
française souveraine est aujourd'hui
dans la souveraineté ce qui manque de
cette volonté de l'état donc oui il faut
des mesures bien sûr que oui qu'il faut
du chômage partiel il faut aider les
entreprises mais il faut aider les
entreprises aussi à être resté or
aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit c'est que
l'état ne sauve que les lobbys mais ne
sauve pas des entreprises il ne sauve
pas des emplois il m'est ne dit toujours
rien sur le versement des dividendes aux
actionnaires
il ne dit toujours rien sur les salaires
mirobolants et c'est bien ça le problème
c'est que on n'a pas une véritable
volonté de sauver l'emploi en france
merci beaucoup à vous je les gagne et je
rappelle que vous êtes oratrice
nationale de la france insoumise merci
d'avoir été en direct avec nous sur arte
france